police in the u.s have confirmed that a
woman has died and a man has been
injured after the actor alec baldwin
discharged a prop firearm on a movie set
the sheriff's office in santa fe said
that mr baldwin came in to speak
voluntarily and no charges have been
filed detectives are investigating how
the gun was fired and what was
discharged let's get more on that now
should we and greg standing by for us
our u.s correspondent hello to you greg
unbelievable what happened
yeah and really serious questions in in
hollywood about how something like this
could possibly happen real shock as well
at what people are learning over the
last few hours and some remarkable
pictures of alec baldwin it seems taken
just after this incident happened on on
the side of a road in in santa fe uh the
police saying that a prop firearm
was discharged fired during the the
filming of a scene in this on this this
very popular filming location what
they're looking into is how it was
discharged and what projectile
came out of it because two people were
hit helena hutchins who was the
cinematographer on that movie she was
airlifted to hospital and pronounced
dead
at the scene the director joel souza was
also injured is still being treated
according to the uh to the latest update
now the production company has said that
this was a scene being filmed with
blanks in that uh prop firearm the
police haven't confirmed that the police
haven't yet said it was an accident
they're saying they're treating it as a
shooting investigation but say it was
uh during the filming of the scene they
say the investigation is active and open
there have been no charges uh no arrests
they're interviewing all of the
witnesses and they have spoken uh to
alec baldwin but as you can imagine a
lot of tributes to helene hutchins
someone who was seen as a real rising
star in in hollywood uh someone who'd
been voted as a rising star a terrible
loss the cinematographers guild
said about her her death and the company
making this film uh say that they're
providing counselling services to
everyone connected with it as they try
to process these these awful events but
a real shock for hollywood and a lot of
questions about how this could possibly
have happened